hello everybody welcome to another
edition of beginner breakdown am your
host my cover and today we are alive at
the Metro class championships very
exciting we got a lot of great players
in the field Danny magaca Keith bass
he's playing today our good friend Mario
Roper and of course a xuong xuong he who
I crushed in the Blitz bounty but before
we get Danny games because it's round
one and no results have come in yet
we're going to take a look at what
happened last night at the Friday action
quad alright so Mario is playing the
black pieces against Ben Lou he used to
be one of my great students and he
graduated on to take lessons from
spencer feingold now right but Mario
he's really good now and he's playing
black so in this position and there's a
lot of spectators around so Mario plays
that move yeah and now Nathan fun Miller
he's there he's like yeah yeah good move
and I'm like dude you can't do that and
so of course Mario kind of loses track
of what's going on and then he's like he
plays that move f5 and then Nathan
familiar and I'm like you're you're out
of the tournament hall ok so eventually
Mario figures out you know checkmate all
right good job good job and then I'll
after the after the match I'm telling
Mario you better go beat this Nathan
fund Miller's you better get them good
because he's making front of you ok so
let's see the match for the eighteen
dollars to see who who wins who ties the
wind of the quad first place in the quad
is thirty-six dollars and there was
another guy that definitely was going to
have to so Mario just had to win and
then you know get 18 bucks so here it
has mario against Nate
fun Miller so Mario starts out with the
Queen pawn and his opponent is playing
for the dragon formation all right so he
attacks Mario's bishop and mario has
progressed he knows hey I don't want my
night or his night to take my bishop and
then I get those kind of weird double
pawns I'd rather have the H file open
attacking your king very interesting so
castle and now Bishop you know you know
it's attacking on the Kings side so all
right Lee five so he's trying to break
open the center here Barrios having none
of it now f5 f5 so really weakness okay
you just let same thing with F 6 a-5 I
know what he's trying to do is like more
is google full for the fork but mario is
having none of it so he gives them a
check King moves and now Mario Goetze
castle long whenever they play on the
dragon formation you probably want to
castle on the other side and just you
know March the H pawn now you don't even
have to march the H point because the H
file is open and notice in this position
a big thing everybody should be noticing
is the King can't move right now so just
keep that in mind so Nate comes out King
to be one so Mario just missed a big
tactic here but luckily luckily Nathan
doesn't see it he's like I'll attack
your Bishop and now Mario is like oh I
see it better late than never Mario okay
so does everybody see how Mario can
actually win the game in this position
night g5 all right help
pure is just like a up snatching that so
fast but good in man so I didn't have to
think so so I like a computer but I
would have saw it obviously alright so
we haven't we have a really good move
here and I might have just showed rotex
pawn Chuck are you crazy yes I go free a
free rook and now rook check and it's
stuck yeah that's over and then check me
just like that hey we have the comeback
of the century in the Class D section
can you believe that everybody can you
believe it oh my god oh my god well here
it is here it is they have my phone is
blowing up let's see the comeback of the
year here alright so so white is a su
shun Cola Colletti against black is Luke
ye you might remember Luke ye in the
king and pawn and game from a couple of
weeks ago that had a massive 17-point
advantage and totally blew it so we'll
see who if he redeems himself or if he
blows another big one alright so looky
playing black takes the rook alright so
pawn takes and so now solution he's
going to advance his pawns I take it a
little slow yeah there's no rush in the
end game right no rush you could know
you want to play as as accurately and
effectively as possible a three should
have never even been a consideration
alright so g5 he wants to get his passer
rolling so pawn takes pawn takes 85 all
right so he's only three away but sushi
and he's like no fear no fear here I
come it's a pawn takes Knight takes
interesting alright so so Luke ye
sitting there he's like this is great
the guy just sacrificed this night I'm
three away from getting a queen how can
I possibly blow this so c6 yeah right
right exactly exactly so so yeah the
spectators are laughing this is why you
never give up an endgame ok so so if you
were playing the black pieces what move
would you play instantly here just to
end all of whites hope bishop CA
obviously and then if that happens he
can just play here ok and the computer
doesn't know what's going on alright but
instead he's like I'm going to go for a
g3 and then he's like a seven-man the
computer is going to be yelling about
this move ok so in this position ok it's
true soutien could get a queen now yeah
yeah or you could just move the king
over so so blacks now blown up you know
a hundred point lead and now white
proceeds to blow a hundred point lead
yeah because all you have to do is play
King to f2 here and and then you get a
queen and go ahead computer doing any
move you want computer I can I can even
beat the computer as white in this
position that's how good I am ok so so
instead
they play the move he can't wait he's
like give me a queen okay and now he's
like can you believe it can you believe
that move he he didn't want to get and
so the game proceeds check Bishop check
forcing the King to stuff to stop the
upon from pomona and I was like darn so
let's see what looky could have even
been thinking about in this position so
he could have got a queen obviously but
he didn't want to write because of check
but look at this check okay all right
computer you want you want a free bishop
you want a free bishop check yeah in
your face and then I'm going to crush
you right I got three pawns and you have
one right so in your face computer and
unfortunately looky he's got to start
playing the endgame better else because
that's second time he's been on the
program and not in a good way alright so
we have a another result from a round
one here Keith bass took on a song zoo
he otherwise known as mr. Martin he all
right so let's see how Keith does
against Zhong Xue all right key has the
white pieces all right so it's going to
play a little advanced french variation
all right right up so Queen to be six so
he's attacking a putting a lot of
pressure on the deep on here and so it
keeps like I maybe I'll maybe I'll go
ahead and attack you so songs ooze like
nope nope all right got the night out
pawn takes Knight takes
Knight takes pawn so all right so you
know whatever you got a free pawn it's
not the end of the world I'm going to
get a lot of checks up here maybe so
Bishop attacks the night a bishop
attacks his night Bishop retreats so we
take he takes the bishop with check
Queen takes back and now we get another
check alright so now when Bishop blocks
and Bishop takes what's the only way
Zhong Xue can take back without losing
material so he's got three different
options right you can take back with the
king the Queen or the night don't want
to take back with an A or you lose the
Queen don't want to take Queen takes
Bishop and you lose the bishop so yep by
process of elimination the king is the
King's the way to do all right so they
castle a night up so this night is in a
pin we should probably think about
attacking it but instead we're going to
attack the defender of the of the piece
that so that's a good idea to and notice
an intermezzo like Knight f3 check
doesn't work because he can take back
with the Queen and protect the bishop so
so zum-zum just retreats back to be 8 h
three then want to be back we're
checkmated mr. alright so rook over
Bishop back keith was in my class last
week where you put the bishop as far
away as possible so now the Queen might
not even realize you know that this
nights in a pen so so interesting so f 6
so f for attacks the night all right so
we got one man out of the way between
the bishop and the Queen this is
very interesting see if we can get some
tactics rolling here it's a queen age
five attacks the pawn he moves it rook
to d1 puts the rook on the same file as
the King so now this pawn in a pin all
right g6 attacks and Keith doesn't want
any any of this because it looks real
rook attacks and then he can force a
queen trade alright so Kiki say I don't
want that Plateau what that poor smart
smart it wants to just try to check make
the guy alright so rook to e6 now one
swing zoo protects it like this we have
a tactic all because the bishop this
hidden hidden bishop in the back it's so
nice is in the still it's in the same
diagonal as the Queen right so do we
have a tactic here what we really want
to say it when we move this pawn in our
dream scenario what's the only thing we
could possibly say in chess that we're
not even supposed to say check yeah
check so if we would take and King takes
we got this big check and we win the
Queen okay so that would be pretty nice
but but unfortunately key keep them let
us see it or didn't see it so he
proceeds with G for you know preparing
f5 here which is good
so night retreats and now he centralizes
his night so now he's really aiming at e
6 so Knight to c6 he takes it anyway
rook up f5 so here's the moment of truth
does young juicy that is queen is under
attack the answer will actually
surprised you the answer is yes he sees
it so check Queen takes Knight attacks
the Queen Queen retreats Knight takes
pawn because we have one two three
protectors and he only has two attackers
so we're doing good so he adds one more
attacker [ __ ] attacks the Queen Queen
to g6 king up Queen check what's the
best way to block this check no a bishop
that would be too passive we want to
actually challenge the Queen so we move
our rook up so I guess he plays Quinn g6
help if you play like a computer you
want to play Queen back to chi 6 and say
play Queen to be three and doubles the
rooks and now he plays rook to f8 and
this is the kill shot from Keith what
move does he make to just like just say
more and just just give it up already so
what move I mean they have to be a
spectacular move but it's just like you
know I'm going to win you want to say oh
now it's your winning move Keith
Bishop takes the pawn right and morrow I
mean it's all just falling apart for him
every got Queen takes pawn coming Bishop
takes rook the best the best defense is
probably rook takes nine that's death no
fun so yeah just give it up give it up
some shoe all right so we're moving
along we're moving along what other game
to have a good friend uh Robert Beekman
playing a white against Marik so so
Roberts got this opening that he likes
to play Bishop a text the night
surprised he hasn't got cancelled yet
but that's alright so Knight to e5 it
it's probably isn't the best so so
there's there's actually two the--can
sidering three things right now if we go
through like the pictures and everything
right that's black to move so we should
be which pie actually considering for
things right here pawn takes pawn Knight
takes pawn Knight takes Knight Bishop
takes Knight and then we all just line
them up one by one by one which one
looks the best alright so so that was
one scenario i think that one pie looks
the best huh the other scenario
yeah doesn't look as convincing as the
other one and then we have night takes
you know but nothing looks as good as
the first one no no we're going to take
something here we're going to take
something all right like something's for
free so we might as well take it we
don't want to be moving our queen I know
which one the computer is going to say
the night that one no no no no look at
this look look at this look look at this
look at how awesome this is it's true
you have double pawns but they're
awesome and if you want it and you have
this d3 coming any time you want it but
this is the okay yeah we all like to
pawn a tech and choice fine fine fine
fine whoo we'll look well look see takes
d4 and it keeps just loving it loving it
and loving it okay got it okay good but
unfortunately a Marik comes up with
Knight takes e4 and so this is this is
what he decided to play so they both get
castled Queen up I've got to get that
Bishop going so Queen attacks the bishop
so Bishop retreats pretty easy and now
he's threatening d4 here so so he takes
the pawn good so that got rid of that so
in this position all right because
obviously the bishop is being attacked
by the Queen right and the Queen's
attacked so name some ways we can save
both of them all right so we got Queen
c7 [ __ ] up the d4 attacks the queen or
bishop
the d6 Bishop f6 just not cutting it all
right so rook attacks the Queen so now
Robert he's getting some stuff he's just
you know I've been there offering that
to take his stuff Roberts going to take
it okay so Queen doubles up so he
retreats bad retreat so what did he just
fall for the pawn for great he was doing
so well he's doing so well so I bishop
threatens the bishop he doesn't want to
play it so f3 check so he moves it out
rook attacks the Queen he puts the Queen
in the same in the same line as the rook
so easy discovered attack right she'll
be yelling out Bishop takes f3 here so
Queen moves so Bishop takes check so
even though it's Queens hanging you
can't take it because he's in check so
King takes Queen check good for Marik
Merrick could trade down to a well maybe
not good for Marik we actually just take
and then if pawn takes I get your rook
and then it's over but he's like you
know what I'm just gonna I'm just going
to check in and check meet you but see
well I got he got the tactic anyway but
do not look at Robert he's like yeah
pumping up my F file i'm aiming right
down at you and Mirax like I don't care
and you'll see that a lot in kids games
and people under 1,200 you know they're
just they just won't eat all your
material and they don't really care
about King safety which is which is
paramount right because your Kings worth
well it's not check made because luckily
he's got to
detectors of f8 it's not checkmate for
the white well what's white to move so
maybe he can figure out some two moves
you know he didn't quite get it he
didn't quite get it so here's a check
here's another check so so if we play
work down here that is not checkmate
it's not checkmate but we can make a
move that threads checkmate and what is
it what move threads checkmate in this
position rook takes e2 if we play work
down here oh we get checkmated but
luckily he was like I play the wheel
brook and now there's no defense to
Queen takes h2 so he just like it really
boxes his king in there just to make it
a funnier at least Robert still has a
sense of humor after all these years all
right so let's see see what other game
okay we got another game from a song Joo
hee let's see if he can get on the board
he's had not having a good day so he's
got the white pieces here all right it's
like III all right so so his opponent
has got castled very quickly kind of a
passive move much better Bishop d3 Queen
d6 and I bet you he cannot resist yep
gotta attack the clean even though it's
not good alright so he gets Castle so so
far so good he's got a lot more space
and he's doing ok so night attacks the
bishop so it takes
night attacks the night captures
obviously when you don't have much space
you want to trade pieces that way you
won't be so crammed up in there so
that's good and Maureen is just letting
him trade and what is wrong with this
this pawn is overloaded so when we take
con takes Queen takes free up free pawn
neck not good Martin so Brooke attacks
the Queen green retreats protects the
sea pawn Queen attacks what's a really
simple way to protect this pawn here
what's the simplest way just move it up
right but all we want to do is move it
up one because if we move it up to Queen
would take Queen takes rook takes all
right so c6 alright Bishop the d3 now
he's attacking the H pawn here so f6 not
a fan of e asleep on takes Queen takes
so he doesn't want to trade so he moves
back so he's threatening Bishop takes
check so he'll either pipelay h6 or g6
so g6 is what's played so now some zoos
like okay I'll trade Queens he's like no
sale efore or a attacks now he's got a
lot of checks here up okay so he plays
with the bishop that's fine so King
moves queen moves are not a good moves
on zoo inexcusable did I just take the
Queen what was he thinking it's not like
I was even check mate or anything that
he was threatening yeah so Queen check
hey don't worry every variation Queen
checked it rook takes pawn why did he do
that
because if rook takes the c1 rick is
hanging so you'll love this move Brooke
to Jeter just ran your face songs ooh
there's nothing you can do about it yeah
I don't think there's any any defense to
at this point sungjoo well actually when
you shove this work in his face that's
when Jung Joo had enough yes I go
because because look there's no defense
to rook takes check Bishop e2 or first
rook the c2 that's first then the show
yeah you don't want to fall for
stalemate here and then writing space
checkmate that's how i were to finish
but i would i would have not let zhang
xue resign i would hope we gotta keep
playing to make just to give me the
satisfaction and look at this our good
friend Mario Roper is on board one in
the Class D section he's got one and a
half points you took a strategic half
point bye in round 11 is a round 2 game
and now is in a position he's got one
and a half with the white pieces against
Brad Baldrige was 2 and 0 so mario has
to go for the win now a draw will do am
no good so so the winner if Mario wins
the game he gets two hundred dollars
makes my 94 dollar bounty look like
peanuts over here okay so in ask mario
before the game which would you rather
have 200-dollars or the class d
championship title direct quote from
mario he said he'd rather have the title
cuz could always just give the two
hundred dollars to charity so the title
will last forever okay alright so let's
see if the if is
wisdom prevails in this game all right
here we go all right so red pinned them
self here so let's see if it works for
them all right so a lot of things a lot
of pawns challenging each other probably
should just calculate and see how to
take button say is going to protect
Mario protects a little bit and Queen to
be 6 all right so he's coming down on
this pawn coming down on this pawn I
don't know if there's going to be an
answer Mario be three be three will not
be the answer so let's see how Brad's
going to punish Mario for a lot of pawn
moves in the opening when he could be
getting castled and it's a pawn takes
pawn pawn takes pawn Knight takes the
Mario should probably get castled here
say takes Queen takes and now Mario is
going to be slick ok it's going to be
like alright I'm going to protect my
bishop by attacking your queen and yeah
Brad's like slamming that check down so
now Mario instant replay for people to
put it on see it earlier
alright who is it oh wait got it all
right so King e2 is played mmm a moment
of truth what does he play in reality
Maria Roper King II to Queen to b4 all
right and Bishop goes back to attack the
Queen Queen retreats Queen see through
so he's got two guys coming down on here
but it's protected two different ways so
but he's like I just play h6 and I'll
just secure it so Rick gets on the same
file as the Queen so Mauro is trying to
generate some chances here which is good
h3 all right rook gets on the same line
as the Queen dangerous but Mario is like
no fear no fear no fear and bring them a
night out so Bishop attacks the night
you can't resist Knight takes bishop but
does the King have to take it no the
night can take so this is not looking
very good for Mario here so Queen
attacks the pawn and the night gets in
the way of it all right so Mario just
goes back to see to all right so so he
takes the night Queen takes the night
pawn takes the pawn pawn takes upon
opening up a discovered attack on the
Queen will Brad suit he does Annie and
it gets an attack on here and an attack
on here does mario have any way to save
both pawns not looking good Maria not
looking good well the one thing is this
queen is protecting this pawn so he's
got that going for
them all right so f 3 ooh excellent
excellent so this Queen if the Queen
takes i like i like i like it Oh
okay and Mario Mario can't take the
bishop because his queens in a pin so
but that's okay Brooke takes the pawn I
don't even think this was a good idea
for Brad to take this point for this
point because it activates this rook so
bad let's check out the engine here
maybe just be six or something our
castle castle rb6 or écarté will give
them a two-point edge both both moves
are fine so now Mario gets his a rook on
the seventh-ranked so maybe you can do
some damage up there so Bishop protects
the pawn Mario challenges the bishop so
Bishop takes King takes and so this rook
cannot come down and do any damage or
because burrows got the big rook check
so how do you think Brad is going to
remedy this well first there's things
first he's got to protect the upon and
now he's aiming two of them up so he's
got to get castled it now so rook up and
so rad does not want to lose it how can
Mario get this pawn in what three moves
any ideas how can he how can he grab
this pawn the rook to a7 yes that's the
idea well no maybe not because he does
not have to take so Mario tries another
way because that way isn't going to work
because he does he is under no
obligation to take in that position so
he plays a 4 here he's and now he
attacks it so now the threat is rook to
be five so he's going to challenge the
rook so Chuck takes and now he gets
behind the pawn and brad is going to
protect the pawn so so Mario still down
upon but his King is more active so
let's see if that's going to benefit him
in the long term King up I guess he was
worried of King up here he might come
down and get these pawns alright so King
/ King up
so now Mario might be thinking about
plane rook here and trading the rooks so
Brad does not want that to happen so he
brings us truck up rook back so now Brad
offers the threefold repetition but we
know the Mario needs a win so he's got
to come up with a different plan here so
he pushes his pawn g4g five now work
attacks the pawn rook the fence so King
up big check rook blocks rip the fence
to pawn again so what move should Mario
play here King b5 just keep going for it
yep King up
and now unfortunately Brad makes a
really dubious move here he's afraid of
a rook to a 6 here so I don't know why
he played this move but you know as long
as you keep playing you know your
opponent might screw up so plays on f5
big blunder here so Mario going to take
a lot of his stuff and maybe try to win
so so he could take the pawn you can
take this point you choose to take that
pawn and Mario is just going to keep
going for for all of Brad's pawns here
rickover so it so now so Mario went from
being down one pawn and having no passed
pawns to having three pass pawns and up
upon so pretty good for Mario big check
so Mario protects the pawn and attacks
it protects pushes and I mean a lot of a
lot of moves win but this this one just
just aunt pretty much ends the game and
gives his opponent no hope here Rick the
g6 right just gets consolidate and it
can't be any easier gets the Queen but
we saw Mario and the Friday action quad
have a little trouble checkmating so
let's see if he can do it better this
time Queen takes
hang up all right so so his opponent
played on for a while and Mario finally
got the checkmate but let's see if we
can just do a let's try to do the most
efficient checkmate possible here what
do you think I know what the first move
is well maybe I don't does it matter
well let's try to do this let's try to
do this within uh let's make it easy
let's let's try to get it within six
moves just to show everybody home what
King to d4 that's got to be the best
move because look we want to get the
King to the back row right so King up
and guess what he has to retreat right
let's try to get a stalemate any
suggestions from I'll play black I want
to go stalemate here so just yell out
anything King III all right all right
don't
corso Queenie one check we probably
don't want to give them a check just yet
see where I'm banking on everybody
playing Queen f2 stalemate right but we
have a really cool move we could just
play Queen to g4 here and now he's only
got two moves and then it's over right
checkmate and Mario did checkmate he won
the two hundred dollars and he is a
rapidly improvement so so good job Mario
roper class d champion all right thank
you for the coming see you next time